one of the essential components of being
the number one in the world or up in
that
place is that confidence the self-belief
and the rest of the world believing it
you can have all the confidence in the
world but if the rest of the room
doesn't buy it
it's nothing
that's funny it's like there's certain
people right with tyson
um
all understand he could not train and
they're still scared yeah right like he
doesn't have to work out that hard
anymore there's several judo you know
this way better but from a spectator
perspective like iliociliatus is like
that he's one of them
it's like he
he's portrayed over the years everyone's
so scared of that
guy it's interesting yep people were
scared of you too
people just gave a certain level of
respect to my skill set
and whether i had a bad weight cut or
didn't have a bad weight cut or not
trained for the last three months which
never happened i'm just saying
they were gonna fight the persona
and it's an important distinction when
you're looking at the top five because
everybody coming up
they're training against the persona
not who you are even i did that at a
younger age
that's why i would always go to people's
hometowns because like i don't i don't
care about the persona i want to know
what you do day in and day out when i
couldn't beat a russian i told jimmy
send me to russia i need to i need to
understand and see it with my own eyes
what they do outperform so that i can
believe
that i can beat them
you